[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Trump is panicking about
Russia it is often hard to be sure what
you are actually seeing when you look at
him there is so much going on so little
it makes sense to ordinary sane eyes but
this this is obviously panic and the
reasons he is panicking may include a
man named Mikhail Kalugin and also a
growing understanding that the key to
Trump's fatal Russian scandal is less
about fake news and more about hacking
the voter registration rolls in about 20
different states before the election
first the panic Twitter bright and early
in the morning turning to his private
intelligence service Fox & Friends he
cannot stop bringing up spying he cannot
stop bringing up Russia but now unable
to find anything else to deflect
whatever his people did he has to invoke
Hillary Clinton's campaign Chairman's
brother his company's legal lobbying for
a bank for twenty eight thousand dollars
a month and then panicking defined did
Hillary Clinton ever apologize for
receiving the answers to the debate just
asking you wouldn't get the answers to a
debate you would get the questions there
are times when Donald Trump must make no
sense even to Donald Trump and in two
other tweets less than 21 hours apart
over the weekend he contradicted himself
first applauding news reporting based on
government leaks to anonymous sources
than condemning news reporting based on
government leaks to anonymous sources
but the panic was not limited to Twitter
common sense would dictate Trump should
never mention any of the following
things ever again surveillance
wiretapping Intel leaking Russia or say
outside things changing the course of a
presidential race Trump Sunday talking
to the Financial Times about the French
presidential race question in France
marine lepen has a very similar message
to you not identical do you think a
victory for her would validate what you
have done here don't answer it don't
answer it don't answer it don't hint
about Russian interference don't hit
about Russian interference don't hit
about Russian interference I don't know
what is going to happen I know that some
out
distractions have taken place which have
changed that race you know some outside
things have happened that maybe will
change the course of that race what's
the French word for panic
Trump is not panicking solo either the
Devon new news story a Profile in panic
if ever there was one is now well
documented that the supposedly
exculpatory surveillance Intel newness
rushed to the White House to loudly
share with Trump who was reported to be
shared with him the night before at the
White House by two or three White House
officials and you may have seen a couple
of Sean Spicer's Baghdad Bob news
conferences recently in which he twisted
himself into such knots that as the
former Justice Department spokesman
Matthew Miller put it according to
Spicer Hillary Clinton has such close
connections to Russia that they
intervened in the election to elect her
opponent that's panic from Trump from
his White House from his pet congressman
but because of somebody named Mikhail
Kalugin Mikhail Kalugin head of the
economics section at the Russian embassy
in Washington Kalugin reportedly went
home to Russia last August after a
six-year stint in this country last week
the impeccable BBC reporter Paul wood
reported that US officials have
confirmed Kalugin was in fact quote a
member of one of Russia's spying
organizations
the SVR or GRU and so what there are a
lot of spies here under diplomatic cover
from a lot of countries except Mikhail
Kalugin may have been the only one who
was first identified as a spy in a
little thing called the Christopher
Steele dossier
the dossier with Trump and the Moscow
prostitutes and the bathroom stuff and
all that a leading russian diplomat
mikhail hooligan steel wrote in the
dossier spelling the man's name wrong
had been withdrawn from washington at
short notice because Moscow feared his
heavy involvement in the u.s.
presidential election operation would be
exposed in the media there in other
words it appears the investigation James
Comey of the FBI confirmed at the house
hearing two weeks ago has not only
nailed Kalugin as russia's key man in
washington working on the last american
election but in so doing it confirmed
yet another critical detail in the
dossier and if that story by itself
didn't cause Trump or somebody close to
him to fly into full-scale existential
panic something else would've the BBC
reported must have the US government
identified Kalugin as a spy while he was
still at the Embassy a retired member of
a US intelligence agency told me that
Kalugin was being kept under
surveillance before he left the u.s.
surveillance of the Russian operative in
Washington trying to help Trump win the
election dates of meetings transcripts
of conversations may be recordings last
August and earlier oops
who else could be on those transcripts
or recordings and then there's what
would have the BBC and several other
less mainstream news sites report that
American intelligence has finally
figured out about what the Russians were
actually trying to do to help Trump win
remember the mysterious news last August
that hackers had accessed the computers
containing the voter registration
records in Arizona and Illinois and then
an ABC report that this was tried in at
least 20 different states and then the
Director of National Intelligence said
there had been probing and scanning of
registration roles quote in most cases
originated from servers operated by a
Russian company and we were all left
wondering why just scan the voter polls
just to prove you could hack the
computers a test run for something no it
seems the voter rolls were the goal
copying them the Russians probing and
scanning and copying the names of
American voters the names the email
addresses the party affiliations of
voters each of whom could then be sent
by email or on Facebook or in a tweet
only the story's most likely to keep
them from voting for Hillary Clinton
stories based on materials the Russians
had already hacked from the Democratic
National Committee stories based on
materials hacked from the emails of John
Podesta
stories not based on anything
micro-targeting it is called but this
would be micro targeting with the best
most specific list of registered voters
that a political campaign could ever get
the actual official government lists
of registered voters the kind of stuff
that would be gold to a political data
mining company like say Cambridge
analytic a whose former vice-president
of the board is or was
Steve Bannon Cambridge analytic up to
five million dollars of the equity of
which is or was owned by Steve Bannon
Cambridge analytical which has its
headquarters in New York City eight
blocks down the street from Trump Tower
Moscow's man in Washington in charge of
trying to help Trump win wiretapped
to borrow somebody's favorite phrase
along with whoever the man happened to
talk to evidence that the Russians may
have hacked the names and online
identities of voters in twenty key
states and did so to steal the data that
companies like the one Steve Bannon was
vice president of would kill for Oh
Donald this is bad I'd panic to resist
peace